المحادثات المرهقه كثيره عبر مجموعات
الدردشه وهذه بعض النصائح للانسحاب منها
دون احراج من الاخرين اولا يمكن وضع
المحادثات الجماعيه بالوضع الصامت كذلك
يمكن وضع كلمات معينه الرد على الكلام
الكثير القادم من هذه المجموعات يمكن وضع
النوم على العادات فمثلا رغبه الاشخاص في
الابتعاد عن الهواتف للراحه قد يكون مبررا
جيدا للهرب من الدردشات الجماعيه دون اي
احراج القول بانك شخص غير مهم في بعض
المحادثات قد يكون مهم جدا لاجل الهرب من
المحادثات الجماعيه فيمكن ان تقول ان هذه
المناقشات ليست بنطاق الصله بحياتك
وبالتالي لا يجب المشاركه بها واخيرا اذا
لم تتمكن من المغادره او الهرب من
المحادثات الجماعيه فيمكن ان تطلب ازالتك
بكل صراحه نظرا لاي سبب تعتقد انه مناسب
لهذا الطلب على كل حال في الاردن قمنا
بتجربه اجتماعيه في الكشف هنكمل مجموعه
واتساب على هواتف الناس نتابع
هلا انا عندي بالواتساب تقريبا فوق عشره
يعني يمكن عشرين جروب
ومثلا في عندي جروبات تعليميه مثلا زي
كورسات انا باخذها فهي بتكون مسكره اصلا
يعني بس انا بتلقى الرسائل ما برسل وفي زي
جروبات اكيد صحبات اكيد بتسبب ضغط او جروب
واحد جروب يعني شغل يعني طلعات زي هيك ولا
مريحه والله عادي يعني شغل بسط مش مش
مزعجه لالي يعني في تقريبا عشر جروبات من
ضمنهم العيله اصحاب
بالشغل
في منها الها داعي في منها منسيه يعني من
زمان كانت بس اللي بتستخدمها يعني
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات